[Music]
what's up real reject nation of the
region yep I'm Greg
this is Anya Anya volt is a comedian and
I will not do that thing where I'm like
tell us joke
monkey perform for us appreciate thank
you but if you don't make me laugh at
least one spot we're filming that is a
bad sign
well that's probably gonna happen no you
know the way that a lot of people the
reason they don't do stand-up is because
they're more conversationally funny I'm
the opposite of that
I'm more stand-up funny and then not
funny and oh yeah totally pick up on
that yeah we're gonna watch this video
from what culture it called 13 best jump
scares in movie history I don't know if
they're just gonna break down these jump
scares I don't know if we're gonna
experience these jump scares but this
was sent over to me and I was like why
not you don't seem like you're really -
in a horror movies are you okay then
that was a lie I don't know I don't know
I've known her for about close to an
hour boy so how does one seem like
they're indoor movies outside of just
being like gothic I can't pick up on
your vibes - well yeah your your
difficult personal bring it close to the
vest yeah I fell you're waiting for like
a very specific person
now I play it close to the vest am i
right headphones on yeah okay great
assemble the headphones these guys are
funny
[Music]
it's fair to say they're one of the more
divisive elements of the horror genre
and films in general really importantly
to achieve shock value rather than
because they serve the story terrifying
what only needs to look at TV show go
pointing of Hill House for tips from
horrifying monster reveals to surprise
endings these jump scares prove just how
effective at Google pry can be in the
right hands strapped in your seat and
brace yourself for some horror content
phantom eyes and problems loose he's got
science fiction masterpiece is generally
heralded for its restraint and slow
building suspense endures occasionally
go Full Tilt horror as with that pad
cramping job scare when Dallas and the
rest of us are surprised by really ready
for a joint slippery idea to come poking
about this face house recheck the
creature as it pops out combined with
the audience's belief at least at the
time that an established star like
Skerritt would survive until the end of
the movie made this one of the most
intense joke scares ever Plus Ridley
Scott opted to pass on the low tension
chords so given how frequently the big
bad alien shows up throughout the film
it didn't feel like a cheap attempt to
shop but rather a
oh yeah
all set up where Mac is convinced that
Gary's in fact the host makes the reveal
that much more shocking no I haven't
seen this one too scared
viewer as Jay is freaking out about
being pursued by this sexually
transmitted supernatural entity known
only as it her friends tried to calm a
dame insistent that she's safe from a
monster based on a Viking history that
will turn her in half if it gets close
enough I suppose that's reassuring
after opening the bedroom door to
another of their pals who even that
scary whoa what is this movie uniquely
unsettling that is correct I have a
story about this one books
[Music]
unquestionably effective and it sure
doesn't yeah right the painting the
conjuring to jump scares those it
especially terrific one in the Contra -
as paranormal investigator Lorraine
Warren follows a vision of the demon
known back into our home office things
get very intense very quickly there she
finds her husband Ed's painting a fact
that he made oh yeah music itself Oh No
then plays the scene with tricks on an
increasingly intercepted Lorraine before
the shadow of bad walks across the walls
of the office and appears to inhabit the
painting then just about anyone that
seen a horror movie before knows that
this scene would culminate in a huge
scare why I managed to get an inventive
job site a bit slow bleeding the scene
for maximum suspense before letting
loose with all the loud noise and CG or
assisted effects
excuse me whilst I just returned my soul
back to my body
oh yeah I freaked out of the theaters
good colleague eyes
[Music]
I'm totally at nowhere settled by the
spooky events taking place in a home she
sits in a kitchen one afternoon and is
surprised by every style found footage
yeah watch the tapes there nosy bastard
that it is uneven use one cauldron work
on the assignment video in which the
camera person is spying on a family
before breaking into their home and
grabbing the family's lawn mower mowing
in the but it's terrifying impact is
undeniable and Oswalt's petrified
reaction pretty much mirrors the
audience's Sinister's roadside scape is
one of the few movies that can get away
such a moment to be honest by the demon
appears course course
[Laughter]
when Josh's mother Lorraine visits and
tells him a dream she had terrorizing
the family his son and instead during
the yeah have you seen there was a third
Exorcist I know nothing that she is
terrified it's pretty much a great
jump-scare unpredictable shocking baby
humorous and superbee directed three
what a plane I didn't clap contouring
hey can you tell alight tanks one it is
introduced early in James 1 smash hit
horror flicks that the parent children
playing a game called hide in cap
fortunately in our first terrifying
children in a big creepy house well one
person are to seek out another by
listening for the clap of their hands
this is put to fantastic use when the
kids mother Carolyn his clapping for a
nice one
and to learn into the basement by a
malevolent entity the lights end up
smashed so parents are lighting a match
to see which point a childlike voice
that is out of the darkness
[Music]
oddly next to carry scaring the living
bejesus out of both her and the audience
it's deliciously simple substituting the
usual tension cord for a thunderous clap
and feels like an organic scare given
its introduction through the kids movie
people clapping in general is scary
anything involving basement stairs
unpopular opinions I get very bored when
I watch it although that is a scary ask
oh oh I gave that big dick energy this
is your number what normally I agree
with you guys the Mel Gibson phone calls
really
[Music]
[Laughter]
thanks for watching
you're welcome I pretty much agree with
a whole list except number one
like I remember watch and the movie and
I'm like whoa yeah but I wasn't like
yeah like freak out like how I've done a
lot of these interesting about this
video is that when I was watching it and
I was like other Ashley it was show the
jump scare there's gonna talk about it
yeah then I'm like I was probably bored
but then when it was a movie I hadn't
seen and they showed it I'm like oh
that's scary I haven't seen it like oh
man it's still there there's something
to be said about how effective is this
jump scares can usually be perceived as
a cheap gimmick as this video mentioned
countless times yeah like we know it's
cheap we know it's cheap let's keep
talking about it I don't know I like
like that's my favorite part of horror
I don't like gore mm-hm and suspense is
like fun but I feel like suspense is
only fun if there's a payoff yeah I mean
a jump scare can be a good tension and
release sometimes it can be cheap yeah
but a lot of people that seems to be
like the cool thing to say is be anti
jump scare no I'm Pro yeah we're pro
John's gonna put me on the record ever
Pro jump scare I should start a hashtag
for it and see what kind of move
we can get going for this we got a Conan
on this progressive stance the
interesting projym scarecrow jump-scare
I say bring jumpscares to your real life
so yeah disagree know who has the best
jump scares Ellen Ellen has the best
chance you never know she does do that
where she scares her guests though and
it's pretty fun yeah I've seen some of
those bits Palin has some great
celebrity bits yeah so I got a couple
stories about the ring okay you met him
briefly before he had to head out I
showed John that because John I've been
friends for like 20 years I showed him
the movie after I had seen it and I
remember when that was Amba moment of
Pete not zombie but the dead girl in the
closet
yeah I showed him that when he was a kid
it's reactional for some reason has been
ingrained in my memory forever cuz it
wasn't like a jump scared he was like
whoa he just went why why did this
happen yeah we all have different
impulse reactions and that tends to be
one of mine as well we're Mike no I
don't want deal with that yeah in the
ring when she comes out of the TV for
the first time was I thought that's the
moment day we're gonna choose when she
comes out of the TV in the finale for
sure I might have told the story before
I remember watching that movie with my
dad it was this weird movie where I've
seen it and then I had shown it to
multiple people as if you I love this
movie here but I show it to my dad we he
was like he was on the living room floor
and he fell asleep in the middle of it
and then he woke up a little bit before
that moment happened he's just on the
ground watching and then when she comes
out of the TV he just starts flip I dad
would like never flip a movie but he
started like screaming at the top those
long because I was like doing this weird
things like rolling lighter right it's
worthy of that reaction it's terrifying
although I unfortunately watched the
ring after I already knew that that's
like the thing you know like that yeah
big deal yeah yeah so I was kind of
for it but it was still scary we see
Mahal in Drive no but I drove on
Mulholland Drive last night specifically
for like because it's a famous it's the
famous Canyon yeah yeah there's a
beautiful lookout I felt like there's a
great jump scare in that movie I would
not know how to effectively describe it
for ya so here's just a footage going
over us talk yeah there you go
yeah David Lynch yeah who offered
provides good jump scares yeah I think
that jump scare if it's well earned and
like properly so that's why I like the
way they broke down this list like with
talking about the clap and the
contouring like they're building but it
just come out of nowhere like what the
hell was that you know have you seen
hush yes what moment are you talking
about just kind of I I don't remember
the specific moment but the way that
they use her big sliding glass doors
several times yes build that he's
watching her yeah and then like that she
can't hear him like him like knocking
yeah all of that that was all like
building towards when she realizes that
he's watching her yeah we're just
necessarily a jump-scare but it is like
a moment where you're like she has to
like run to the door and like slam I'm
sorry watch the movie watch watch the
movie you guys ever seen hush that's a
great it's a really good movie I noticed
where all of these other than jaws where
all of these supernatural horror movies
but I feel like for the most part they
were I feel like especially with is in
the realm of jump scares that it can be
easier a plot it feels less cheap with a
supernatural thing whereas in real life
a lot of the time we can hear it coming
but what's great about hushes that you
can't because you're because she can't
hear that's because it's like in real
life for like slashers and stuff yeah
cuz even they reference Friday the 13th
which the first one is realistic to a
degree but that jump-scare moment is
coming in a dream sequence yeah actually
I think something that easily could have
been way above signs I've seen the movie
Carrie yeah at the end when she's having
a dream about visiting Carrie's grave I
think Carrie pops her hand out of the
that moment haunted me yeah I was
absolutely terrified I'm getting nipple
chills just thinking of that is a scary
ass moment yeah chilly nips chilly nips
in the building the chilly willy nips
and now shag chilly nips chilly nips
I know people hashtag nipple chills but
no chilly nips we're gonna change it up
thanks Sonia you've changed my
catchphrase how you doing your creative
time yeah bring me in to consult fresh
tags I really like movies that employ
stereotypically paranormal movie tropes
yeah for non paranormal scenarios sure
sure so like hush is a really good
example of that maybe a divisive opinion
but vacancy that movie about I have a
Luke Wilson yeah yeah that movie also
not supernatural but because there is
like this whole system in place that
these people have to systematically kill
people it's a little bit otherworldly
while being realistic usually in the
realistic horror you still have to
suspend your disbelief yeah yeah for me
the most unrealistic part of vacancy is
that the people who kill them leave the
videotapes of killing other people in
the hotel rooms yeah it's a little silly
they are able to prepare they're like oh
they're gonna come try to kill us now
yeah like you're equipping these people
with the ability to greatest game ever
played man that's kind of the whole like
saw tactic - yeah you let them in on it
and then you still don't have a choice
but to play the game that's how you make
it a challenge dude yeah it's true it's
true I'm sorry I didn't mean to
criticize the critically vacancy yeah
great movie though like as far as just
being entertained for an hour and a half
goes true I was thoroughly entertained
also gotta be honest last time I watched
it I was in middle school so it could be
- know it holds up it gets better with
age it's like a fine wine yeah vacancy
oh man go check it out don't watch
vacancy today be hashtag bring back baby
back vacancy nipple echip Alize alright
well that's it for this one
you guys just subscribe to what culture
you can subscribe to the reject nation
but more importantly make sure to follow
on you
on Instagram and Twitter I'm flying out
to New York to join her for a collab and
the only way she'll let me come on her
channel or be featured in her next live
stand-up performance is if she gets at
least 5 more followers video you lowered
the bar yeah that's why I do yeah always
I have very I'm an underachiever I was
hoping for 10 but five is a five is okay
yeah add it with the last video fifteen
you'll be good yeah see you guys bye bye
we have an insight yeah yeah